so now we get to the sticky end of
things and I ask us this question again
I'll give you the exact wording it says
examine the behavior of why as X
approaches infinity and has deduced that
it also has two inflections okay so
we'll do what part of time because
there's an easy part numbers oh hi I
examine the behavior of X approaches
infinity let's have a look at this thing
right there it is right there as X
approaches infinity now there's two
interesting things happen and they
collide right and this is where our work
without with further graphing will help
us a little bit what plus adds all swear
what's it doing as X approaches it also
is approach infinity it's just climbing
off it's a parabola isn't worthless X
Squared's us off its going right but the
socks are just quickly draw that this
guy is going up right what I eating the
negative x what's that to it yeah it's
drop you like a wrong it's going down
and it's it's approaching x equals y I
presume okay now when you look at these
two and you're taking the product it's
not immediately clear what's going to
happen like there's this tug-of-war
thing happening right which one is going
to weird no it's kind of funny because
you can do if you do the shape of it
like it's more like I said it's not
obvious right and you might think okay
well this guy is um is dropping down
slower but it looks like he's slowing
down yes it kind of looks like that
that's a little bit deceptive okay
here's the way you could in fact it's
the exponential the winds any
exponential any exponential like think
about its derivatives look at that is to
remove so for example we said something
like and this is this is actually a
different base okay just think about
this guy for a second just the rail room
by definition what is here
the answer okay so when you think about
its greatness you think about its
gradient its gradient is either going
crazy steep just like this is right or
it's dropping really really fast right
because if it's on the denominator is
doing the same thing like this is
shrinking at the same speed this is
growing right in other words really
really fast okay whereas when you think
about this guy where is if there is one
place where we in fact already did this
I'm going to do incredible before what
happens to you he turns into that right
now you compare those now now it becomes
a little more obvious right like yeah
it's getting he's going to get smaller
that's right it's going to get bigger
but the rate of which is doing it is
what's slowing down if i differentiate
again it slow down slow down and that's
what polynomial do every time you
differentiate the degree will drop down
but no matter how many times you
differentiate an exponential you will
still get an exponential of song variety
right so therefore these guys will
always win always every time okay so
we'll talk a bit more about like how you
there's another result going to show you
later today not sure if it's going to be
this lesson more in the afternoon where
we'll do this same kind of process but a
little more rigorous Oh to show you when
you're comparing these students of it
okay so the rule of thumb to remember is
this expedit you will always win in fact
Exponential's with in comparison almost
everything except for these guys which
is why they have that symbol anyway
that's beside the point you don't need
to worry my brain here oh yeah well I
mean in principle I mean when we think
of it yes what do you think about
visually thinking about it if you think
about like a parabola versus an
exponential versus a factorial like for
us for our puny human is it's like well
they just all look like increasing
beings right but you start to compare
the numbers like I give an example um
okay enough anyone's seen you some this
trip before I don't have one with me um
if you have a deck of cards right a deck
of cards if you know how many ways can I
arrange this deck of cards right it's
like well what I'm now I'm not thinking
about something to meet in turn three
but you guys can work this out the first
card that I pull out there could be 50
different cars it could be
fizzy two different cards so that's how
many possibilities there after the first
one we have a look at the next card down
I've taken one kind of play there's
still 51 left right so then yes yeah and
then for every card down right I'll get
all the way down to one and that would
give me the 52 cards in the deck now
this number right like I've only counted
252 okay like my somebody was three
could count to 50 to this is not a big
number okay but this is like I think
this is ah man I know I know what the um
I don't know what the other number at
the front edges notation on it but i'm
pretty sure it's 10 to the 67 as a 67 it
is right now this is this is like um uh
I 171like this is really if it's a tumor
5230 it should be bigger than yours
should easy go oh yes oh yes everyone
okay now uh this is this number is so
astronomically large like if you can
compare to if you hadn't argent people
right and they were just dealing out
decks of cards like every single second
they could deal at a whole deck of cards
the number of seconds that the universal
existed according to like what women say
that big bang is 10 to the 18 seconds
ten to the 18 seconds if you've got a
hundred people doing that you just want
5 100 x 10 to 20 you're still 4700 so
that the trick but they say is you know
if you deal a deck of cards there's
every likelihood that that deck of cards
has never ever been dealt in the history
of the universe because there are just
so many decks of cards that can be drawn
right now that's that's what the
factorial function is doing like that's
the insanity of its growing where is
like exponential growth we've actually
we experienced exponential growth all
the time in like populations like virus
or something like that will grow
exponentially but it's nothing like this
like this is quite literally it's off
the plan any so all of that just to
establish this guy wins right there's no
ends so remembering that this is
shrinking this is growing but this
shrinking has more significantly right I
would say this
this is part c limit as x approaches
infinity of Y of that function it's
going to approach zero right let me to
the negative x it wins and if the
negative x is going down to the earth
okay then they say right if you can that
it's so understated if you know that can
you draw a conclusion that there are two
infections hmm